the exhibition is called messages across
time and space the new Fiat drawings
from the 1890s at Columbia University
these drawings have been in the
collection of Columbia University since
1935 when Professor Wendell tur Bush who
was a professor in the philosophy
department specializing in religion
donated his large collection of objects
to the University and it was actually
installed in 401 low library and on
public display for several decades the
reasons that this exhibit was
particularly appealing to us and we
thought it was a good fit is that it was
working with not only a guest curator
but also a collectively curated show
that included faculty and students and
that was part of a course I was able to
come to the class as a result of the
consortium which allows students from
different schools around the New York
Manhattan area to take classes at other
institutions Columbia hired its first
curator for its art properties
collection about a year and a half ago
and he started reaching out to faculty
to tell them some of the treasures that
were in Columbia's own possession that
we didn't know anything about and so I
discovered long into my time here on
campus that there were three to four
hundred Native American objects here on
campus that I could make use of with my
students and in my classroom but
kinds of objects being used in the
drawings they're very unusual you'll see
like mittens that go all the way up to
your you know above your elbows and
these very elaborate parkas and the
artist really gave a lot of attention
and detail to those kinds of textures
and materials and the drawings so when I
saw them I was really curious about why
so much attention was given to those
things in addition to the physical
exhibition here in the gallery we've
created a web page a web exhibition and
of course we want that to be available
not only to an audience with a scholarly
interest in these drawings but also to
be available to the village of King
daguan in Wales Alaska which is where we
believe these drawings were made about a
hundred years ago it's important to be
able to preserve the materials that
allow us to study and share aspects of
that experience then on the other hand
is once they're deposited in the library
what kind of efforts are made so they're
not just a dead archive but actually a
living archive to be able to share those
materials and they don't only live in
the archive